UNDER WAY.
THE SLOT.
A QUICK SHOT OVER THE TOP OF THE
NET OFF THEASIDE.
SVECHNIKOV LETS IT COME BACK AT
THE LINE.
DEMELO WITH THE AWAY. DETROIT R.
BACK AT THE LINE FOR  MONTREAL
ABOUT A MONTH AGO WITH A
AND DRIEDGER MAKES THE SAVE.
AND WE'LL LOVE.
THOSE CONNECTIONS, THOSE
RELATIONSHIPIP KEVIN SAWYER
EARLIER.
HE SO GOOD TO ALL
OF THESE GUYS, WHY DID THEY
LEAVE?
Y DRIEDGER.
>> Kevin: HE'S BEEN
THAT ONE HAD A BIT TOO MUCH ON
IT FOR HARKINS TO HA
FORCED TO THE OUTSIDE.
TAKEN TO THE SIDE BOARDS BY  SH.
SAVE
SIDE.
BENIERS WITH THE WRISTER
COULDN'T DRIVE IT THROUGH.
BENIERSDY TO THE JETS' BENCH.LE
>> Kevin: THAT WILL BE HIS
LINE.
THANK YOU.
I'M
THE JETS HAVE HAD A LITTLE BIT
TROUBLE IN THE DEF 22 OF THE LA.
FOR KYLE CONNOR.DRAG THERE BY
HE HAS COME SO CLOSE IN THE LAST
FEW  ITON IT ISOT,
SCORES!
BLAKE E
THAT IS CLEAN.
HE DOES IT IN HIS OWN IDENTITY,
HE WILL DUMP IT OFF FOR JANSEN
HARKINS.
HARKINS GOES  US THE CALL WE
AWAY.
PAUL STASTNY, T
HE WILL SEND IT AROUND FOR
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS.
IN FORHREE TO
GO DENNIS.
NUMBER 40 ON THE SERE-LUC DUBOIS
WHO'S ONE POINT SHY OF TYING HI.
CAN'T.
SOUCY FROM THE LINE.
THAT GOT DEFLECTED BY DONSKOI
AND A